sponsored by step finance your go
to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh pen
show this is sponsored by blockfi if you're
entering or if you are interested in block by um
and the interest rates that they offer then i've
left the description for you um and the link for
you in the description in the comments section
um i think right now they're probably offering
some of the most competitive interest rates given
many companies are slashing so i definitely
recommend um checking them out so today we
are going to be talking about all the hot stuff
we're talking about censorship we're talking about
the establishment and we're talking about the
general narrative towards crypto and joining me
for this discussion today is frank chaparro
the news director at the block let's bring
frank in hey frank how are you i'm good i i
like your your foliage in the background there
well this like this yeah very impressive thank
you i made it myself actually my mom is me
good good yeah thank you so how are you doing
i'm pretty good i'm pretty tired a lot of um
roaming around a lot of crypto conferences
so i'm happy to be back in my house so i can
get back into my routine um but it's been
a lot of fun i mean the space is really
it's really energetic despite the sort of
sideways price um situation i have never
seen so much exuberance happiness you know people
relaxing maybe after sort of you know an arduous
you know couple of years so it's been fun and it's
nice to kind of be a fly on the wall so to speak
and and get to cover a lot of these different
conferences and events and i've been doing
at each one i try to do at least one write-up
to to get a sense of exactly what's at the
center of the discourse and conversation is
so it's fun i'm doing i'm doing pretty good
okay so for those that don't know
you've just gotten back from the bahamas
where the ftx conference took place and
something which really struck me about
that conference now obviously i wasn't there um
i haven't heard much feedback or seen much yet
but something which really struck me was the fact
that um tony blair so for those that don't know he
was previously the prime minister um of the labour
party in the uk um over like a decade ago i think
it was the early naughties probably um and then
there was bill clinton in the 90s oh no we say
naughties naughties is like 2000s oh he was so
he that's early 2000s or all of the two naughties
interesting yeah americans never know what i mean
when i say naughties but it's the 2001 2002 2003
yeah because it's not not got it not because they
were a naughty period of time that's probably a
little bit of both but um what struck me really
was the fact that bill clinton and tony blair were
speakers now i think most of the community were
quite confused by that um so i'd like your take
why do you think that's part of it definitely
so i think part of it is part of it has to do
a little bit with ftx and part of it has to do a
little bit with salt uh if you know the history
of salt and i got to get a bit of it from um the
man the myth the legend himself anthony scaramucci
it kind of came out of the financial crisis a
lot of the the sort of the the the sentiment
out of washington post financial crisis was very
anti you know flash with cash flush with cash
uh conference going among uh the titans of finance
so basically pre-financial crisis you'd had all
these events all these like really fancy um
dinners around conferences and whatnot and they
wanted to put uh the sentiment was you know
don't do that right a lot of people lost a lot
of money um and so the mooch kind of came in with
saul as a way to you know revitalize that scene
um because at least from his perspective
you had a lot of hotels in places like vegas
that weren't getting the same um action
the same um you know traffic so to speak
and so he started this as a way to
revitalize that scene but it's always been
it's always been about bringing in outside
speakers not just from within wall street but
from the political realm the regulatory
realm the business and technology realm
and have representatives um speak on topics that
may be peripheral or tangential to finance but
nonetheless relevant so i think when you see
any sort of politician at assault event it's
it's connected to that i also think that the
when you think about the the presence of more
maybe um i mean obviously both were more
uh relatively more liberal than than other
presidents and prime ministers um i think sbf
and he's talked about this is is rather keen to
present a picture of the space that is very
dynamic from a political perspective um i
think some people outside of crypto think of
it as very monolithic in nature right you have
some of the louder voices like a ted cruz
or cynthia lumus kind of making the most
headlines about being pro crypto and then some
of the people who make the most headlines of
being anti-crypto would be some someone like
senator elizabeth warren of massachusetts so
if you have someone like a bill clinton and
tony blair at a crypto conference it might
give um a signal to certain people in the
political glitterati that it isn't just some
sort of or at least not all of it right isn't some
sort of like libertarian um anarchist community
it's very dynamic it's very multifaceted we can
get these um different types of folks to come to
our conferences and and speak about leadership and
and and maybe how crypto can do good for the world
um and honestly i think i think it's it's
it's accurate of of how the political
sort of the political breakdown is of crypto it's
not necessarily a right or left thing um when you
when i think about what folks on the right like
about crypto it's kind of like you know keeping
the power of government small or minimizing it
but when i think about what the left might like
about it it's you know banking the unbanked it's
providing better financial tools than the tools
that exist for um you know folks more um you know
in the lower rungs of the economic louder ladder
right um you know the left really should should
and people have have pontificated about this um
you know elizabeth warren should really like
crypto because it's it's effectively anti-bank and
what what do um sort of um liberal populists not
like about the banks they take advantage of the
little guy overdraft fees etc so i think that's
how i would um break it down a bit of sort of
a bit of history of the historical sort
of way salt conferences are operated and
then this broader um push among um sam to really
evangelize for a more politically dynamic um space
and he's doing a lot of diplomatic
answer okay that's a very diplomatic
well i think i think some people right i mean
some people were kind of confused in as much as
you know is it is it trying to make
crypto seem too um leftists i think that's
that's one argument i think another argument
is that it might add an element of balance
i understand and i think i think it is good
to have individuals there who are from outside
of the space and um from many different
um you know with many different diverse
um political beliefs i just think that the
problem i mean i can't really speak too much to
bill clinton because like i'm not american um but
the problem that i mainly find with tony blair
is he is the biggest advocate for um for um what
are they called uh like they're just basically
digital ids um he's been pushing him since the
iraq war which he started so that's my biggest
issue you know he's sort of pushing digital
ids cbdc's the whole thing um vaccine passport
very much any taking any global emergency
to track and trace people um so i feel
for me personally i felt like he's an
enemy of everything that crypto stands for
yeah i mean i don't know much about him
myself aside from that movie the queen
oh right okay i haven't seen one only i think
helen mirren starred in it and she was she plays
the queen during um you know princess diana's
death and that is probably and there's you know a
bunch there's a lot of tension between um i forget
the actor who played tony blair but tony blair
and the queen and that's probably that
is the extent of my knowledge of his uh
tenure as prime minister so i i kind of have to
plead the fifth in that respect but i do i mean
listen i think you're gonna find it on
on both sides if you look at any like
person pounding the table or at least becoming
crypto curious they're gonna have an aspect of
what they've said or what they believe
in that does not necessarily jive with
all of the tenants of uh decentralization or
the cryptocurrency community and i think that's
okay right like i think the more people who can
get in the room and and engage with different
um community members is important but at the
same time right this wasn't necessarily a deeply
you know crypto conference right yet a bunch of
financiers and investors and so um that's it's
a draw to have someone who has held high office
uh at one of these events because then you can
sort of like you know um you know rub elbows with
them you know i saw giselle that was pretty cool
um tom brady's wife oh i have no idea
yeah i only know who tom brady was in
the last only found out who was in the last year
see that's there you go i mean that's that's proof
is in the pudding that the crypto's empowering
these folks is uh brands yeah but it was really
it was really interesting i mean like i have never
i mean it's just first off the scene there like
what they're doing in the bahamas is is just it it
seeing it up close and in person was far
beyond what i could have imagined like they're
they're redefining this small country and and the
prime minister um obviously had a big presence at
the conference and all the local well at least you
know i didn't speak to every single inhabitant of
the island over 400 000 people but they they're
they're cool with it they're like really like this
is this is this is really exciting you know for
our economy and so many people are following in
their footsteps so you're gonna have about i mean
you can have dozens of companies in the crypto
space based in bahamas and it it mimics kind of
the the the strategy of uh francis suarez in miami
um and and other you know local leaders who
want to attract this talent this development
and this community which is obviously
you know affluent but they're going to
be they're going to build an office space
they broke ground the week of um bahamas
uh crypto bahamas that can house like a thousand
people tied in some way to sbf his charitable
philanthropic efforts the the company uh
the different companies he runs and then
some of the investments in portfolio company
companies that that he touches all there and
they're all so many of them are already
there and it's um it's really it's really
oh it's almost kind of bizarre in some
in some ways because it just happened
overnight but that's the ftx story like this
like he the whole story is an overnight story
um and you know you never know what shoe is going
to drop you nothing is ever predictable but it's
it's pretty it's pretty insane and they're not
the only ones right i mean i mean uh you know
i think there's there's this shift this tide
that's shifted when you when i think about the
various places i've gone over the past few weeks
um even in paris right um you know macron gave an
interview with this um uh a journalist friend of
mine about crypto and and they're super keen to
bring in some of the the innovation from from
london you know this is almost like uh uh the
hundred years war reimagined but in in terms
of crypto right you know france versus the uk
and they're they're battling it out but instead
of you know in ships they're they're doing it with
with different companies to incentivize them to
be there and then even in dc the there's there's
been this like awakening to the you know i used
to go to dc and not that i'm that important but
i mean people people now know like what the
block is which is pretty interesting you know
gary gensler looks at our dashboard but i was
hobnobbing with different dc types while i was
there um i wasn't invited to the white house
correspondent dinner but maybe next year and
these people like they're all getting into crypto
and the policy folks it's like really it's really
interesting um how much of a force it's become
because all of these companies now are starting to
hire policy um and government relations folks to
to advocate on their behalf i was talking with
kristen smith at the blockchain association the
amount of money um from from a lobbying pers or
from a um sort of individual donor perspective one
from zero to like you know has has effectively um
you know uh now amounts to the tens of millions
and so everywhere it's like it's become this like
force of nature um which is really which is really
not necessarily captured in the mainstream press
i talk about this a lot crypto more broadly
in in the sort of the zeitgeist of media is
is still defined or stuck within the parameters
of very specific and old narratives that have
that have been um commonplace for several years
one of which that i see time and time again i
saw it this morning in a story in the wall street
journal um you know the the sec is hiring uh 20
um new uh staff or to to sort of monitor do
something with crypto and in the um i don't know
if it was the lead per se or in the meta um will
bring the unregulated market into the purview of
u.s regulators and it's like how do how does this
perception and this isn't just the journal i mean
it's i see it all the time how is this perception
that crypto is unregulated like still like how can
you factually say that like how can like wha
how is that a fact when new york um department
of financial services oversees most of the crypto
exchanges here in the us coinbase has to answer to
their authority um you know you have a firm like
genesis global which is a registered broker dealer
sure i guess you can say none of the
exchanges are federally regulated exchanges
but that's not the same as being unregulated right
i mean these firms uh many of them are regulated
in some degree or another so that's like
one narrative and like one misconception
um which is i'm gonna just jump in there though
because there are there are a lot of narratives
and we can we can go through them um one thing i
just want to quickly refer to is when you spoke
about london and paris and even dc with more um
with more people and more countries coming into
the space i still sort of stand by the idea that
they're not coming in in a good way they're coming
in in terms of oh i see blockchain technology i
see it as a form of surveillance through cbdc's
um so when we see that kind of adoption i think
that's the sort of adoption from these main these
major places i mean you mentioned macron macron
was pushing vaccine passports terribly i mean
in his own words he wanted to make the lives of
unvaccinated people um very very difficult i mean
he said he wanted to piss them off and i literally
quote um so i feel like these are people who don't
have good and fair intentions when it comes to
individual liberties and freedoms um so they're
coming into this space for sure but i think
that they'll use the technology in a bad way
i think honestly i mean i'm sure there's
there's a bit of that like you know certain um
certain folks have a different view of of
surveillance and so maybe they do see blockchain
as a way to you know incorporate effectively
gr uh have more power over um the folks
to whom they're they're supposed to lead or
govern um but i think i think it more so boils
down to jobs right like you don't want to be the
person that's chasing jobs away and even if it's
you know the secondary or tertiary reason for
wanting to incentivize people to operate and
do business in your country i think i think it's
a powerful one um like if you look at the amount
of employees that many of these companies uh
employ uh it's not in the hundreds anymore
it's not in the thousands it's in the tens
of thousands and the hundreds of thousands um
maybe not hundreds of thousands
but certainly quite a number of
people like we've even grown at the block from
you know a year ago 30 people to over 150 and
i'm sure that we would you know explore different
um um jurisdictions that you know where there's
there's a vibrant sort of um and even if
it's not like a financial incentive just like
knowing that um they they've got your back
and that they're keen to work with you and
and support you which is something i think that
mayor suarez has done a good job of doing it that
the actual like implementation of crypto is kind
of ambiguous like yeah there's maybe a miami coin
thing or you're gonna maybe try to do taxes it's
like but that's like that's like all right like
you know or and then to your point like
sure maybe they're like all right we want
to figure out how we can do cbdc's but i think
at the end of the day they want to go back to
their constituents and be like hey we got this
company that wants to hire a thousand people
to either not leave or set up shop here and then
employ people within our jurisdiction and then
that translates into downstream economic impacts
restaurants drivers and and uh the like so um
i think that that's like i mean look like like
let's be honest like why does ted cruz like
care about this space so much because you've got
exxon mobil looking to see uh and different gas
companies looking to get into crypto mining and
he sees all these miners coming to texas and like
those are you know who's gonna butter his bread
um but but that's also good because then you know
that to to degree the the the more that um the
sort of power of the individuals operating the
space is recognized by people in power the
i mean it does it has a trickle-down effect
or at least puts a stamp of legitimacy onto a lot
of the work of what um you know we're doing here
so let's go into journalism you were um sort of
touching on that earlier i think that there's
definitely these really bizarre narratives that
keep popping up um just a few weeks ago there
was a crazy headline which was calling bitcoin
as psychopaths saying that they are financially
illiterate um and then we have the whole bitcoin
mining is going to destroy the environment so
my question to you is do you think that they
genuinely believe the rubbish that they say
you come from the traditional uh journalism world
so you tell me yeah when i was at npr affiliate
um you know we used to talk about if
it bleeds it leads so that's sort of um
that's sort of uh true and i guess you would
agree in in financial journalism um but listen
i think um it's like you everybody operates
within the the confines of their own
view of the world right so if you kind of think
of crypto as unregulated or um mainly useful for
criminals and you don't really know like you
know the back office accountant who works at
gemini or coinbase like you don't know that it's
normal people who you know also take their kids to
you know daycare and drive around and like
you know bmws in your nice neighborhood
then you probably don't think that they're normal
people you think they're all like shadowy like
psychopaths maybe but so i i don't think that's
the case with all um journalists i think that's
broadly you know people who aren't in crypto
would would think about it or not think about it
so let's say you get a let's say you
get like data from chanalysis that
shows that the amount of um illicit activity
has increased to i think i don't remember the
exact number but let's say it was like 1.5 billion
and it increased or doubled from the year before
you look at that and you think okay
i understand that there's this like
broader you know there's all these hacks and
crypto was used in the dark web because those are
those were the prevailing stories so okay so it's
increasing so the story is that it's increasing
and since that's the confined uh or
the parameters in what you're thinking
it's just building on it's just building on
the blocks that you have no pun intended um
whereas if you've been in the space long
enough and you see it has gone from fairly
sophomoric in nature to now you know the
exchanges have done their sock ones and
suck twos and they've hired all these people from
wall street and all these developers from google
and you see the amount of action happening on
regulated platforms and you see the headline
number as a percentage going down from i think it
was two percent to a half of a half of a percent
then that's that sticks out to you so for me i'd
say okay look illicit activity is going down which
makes sense because the crypto market's maturing
but if you don't have the that background then the
the sort of former story as i outlined is
easier to sort of like put together in your mind
and i think that's the case with a lot of
different um long i mean these are really sticky
narratives um the esg one as another example
and then more recently the sanctions narrative
as well right like i think it's it was such a hard
thing to sort of explain because most people don't
understand i don't certainly i don't understand um
you know of sanctions as as well as you know some
very serious policy people or geopolitical
experts but a lot of people don't understand
that and they don't understand crypto so when you
kind of mix the two together and you and there's
already this underpinning narrative that none of
the crypto exchanges like are regulated at all
it built this like powerful like really powerful
message that all crypto exchanges are breaking
sanctions which obviously wasn't um the case
right because sanctions were not at the time
you know you have to do no business with with
russians it's it was specific characters specific
oligarchs um but when you think that crypto
exchanges are already unregulated you just assume
or you can assume that then they are dealing with
these types of actors because why wouldn't they be
they're unregulated and these wild west venues
of of people who are faceless and nameless um
so i think it's just a degree of like
unfamiliarity with with the degree to
which the space is matured and an unfamiliarity
with like who are the main actors and and people
um and that translates into stories that are
somewhat out of touch i think with where um where
the market is i think we've been lucky enough to
have um you know we grew up in this bear market
uh the firm and have stuck by it we have
very low retention um and we got to see
these builders kind of come back um out of
the ashes um and so there's a bit of like
there's a bit of um there's a bit of context
that that adds whereas at other outfits um
you had the 2017 run-up and then as that grew
as you saw the drawdown um most media outlets
had their crypto journalists sort of like leave or
move on to other beats and then now you have a new
wave of folks i would say who are just starting
to get acclimated and they want to tell they want
to you know you want to tell tough stories you
want to make a name for yourself as a journalist
and i that's you know what's what i tried to do
and when i started at the block we told a lot of
a lot of tough stories about you know basis
unwinding and you know the blockchain terminal
scam and bitfinex's banking hiccups and the
breakdown noble bank i was actually or deltek
or deltek's relationship with and x um i saw that
guy in bahamas he was like you made my life hell
but it's all cool um and so you know you want
you want to do that you want to come out and tell
really good stories but i think like there is this
gap between like the maturity level um or the sort
of like reputability of most crypto businesses
and the perception of their reputability
and and maturity and there's mistakes i mean like
you know open c is a pretty good example like they
i mean they i think at the uh last fall were seven
people and now they're worth 13.3 billion dollars
in valuation so you know when you grow that
fast you're gonna make mistakes but and it's
fine to point out those mistakes but i think
there's a difference between reporting um
being tough and and sort of holding power to
account and coming oh there's a difference
between that and coming to the space from a
basis that the entire thing is without merit
and i think that when you you come at it
from that you're you're telling pretty boring
stories if you come at it with a with a with a
degree of curiosity and a degree of skepticism
maxed with a degree with a degree of respect i
think you're gonna get really great stories um and
and ask really good questions because the people
are interesting like i mean it's it's unbelievable
um some of the the founders that have come out
of the bear market and and what they're doing um
i mean at least from my
perspective and i i would i would
beseech um you know journalists out there in
the mainstream to look at those stories um
because it's it's pretty it's pretty
crazy i think what's fascinating um
i'm i'm i'm fascinated by your your sympathy
for the stories and the reason why i say that
is because i from from what i from what i gathered
from what you said it sounds really just like
um they just don't know um my pro my problem with
that is um so go educate yourself before you write
a story i mean i used to work for chinese global
tv network as a correspondent i was based in paris
and god forbid i started to write a story which
i did not fully know about oh my god i was told
to call every expert i knew about whatever i was
covering so i was covering trade wars right i was
actually covering a story between macron and um xi
jinping um the the trade situation and i was under
strict instructions to know the story inside out
um because you're a journalist that is that is why
journalists hold themselves to such high degrees
that's why you know journalism used to be um you
know the god's truth it used to be the ultimate
thing that everybody sort of um really respected
and you know people really held journalists to
account now nowadays for many different reasons
journalism has lost its um lost its value and its
credibility um so i'm sad that that if this is the
case well i think it's sad until for two reasons
number one if it's done on purpose that's sad
um number two if it's done out of just a lack of
understanding about crypto therefore a lack of
sort of education that's even more sad um you
know there's so much information out there um
with regards to the whole esg narrative i
mean even calling bitcoin as um illiterate
and psychopaths come on that's not laziness
that's that's pure hatred um what do you think
um so nick carter changed his twitter bio to a
illiterate financial psychopath and i i didn't
i didn't have the context for that so maybe
i'm not doing my job but i thought did someone
i mean i was like no there was some there was
some article that said i mean listen i don't know
i i honestly i wouldn't be i'd like
to see the data on on the uh on how
uh the average bitcoin person is is more
illiterate than the average non-bitcoin person
well exactly that's what i'm saying it could
be could be true there's no data i don't know
there's a lot of there's a lot of um there's
a lot of questionable people everywhere but um
what i think it is is listen like it's a it's a
it's a red-hot it it has captured the mindshare
of the entire world right i mean katy perry was
at this conference in the bahamas so uh and paris
hilton is is very active i heard from someone down
there that she was doing due diligence on on on
on a crypto fund that i know so it's captured
the attention of of the mainstream jimmy kimmel
so news outlets are really trying hard to put as
much resources into this as possible and putting
fairly green reporters onto the scene and you
know i i do think you know that they're doing
the best that they can and i think we are too like
everybody makes mistakes and gets things wrong but
um i had an editor used to say there but for the
grace of god go i um whenever there'd be a funny
mishap that would happen at arrival um so do i
think it's you know i don't know i i understand
i do think some of it's like if some of it gets
under my skin too and i'll see certain things
i'm like this is just like come on
just talk to people just talk to
just talk to anybody like talk to it literally
and they'll talk to you that's the other thing
like they're so much more open than any bank or
any sort of you know large insurance or technology
company like and from my perspective they're
also really open to talk about how they've
messed up and what they need to do better um just
just do that but i you know uh my grandmother
why yeah i think that because there's just so
much there's so many stories and uh maybe they're
under a degree of pressure maybe these narratives
that i talked about earlier are so pervasive that
you know at the end of the day like you
know some of it isn't like it's not on
it's not it's all about perception right like it's
not inaccurate to say that something is x um like
it's not inaccurate to say that the amount
of like illicit transactions is going up
even though as a percentage it's going down
it's just like the way you look at it and it's
a huge misrepresentation it can be but i think
that it's not it it's it's a misrepresentation
when you have the context but the thing that the
thing that i would say and maybe it's naive maybe
i'm i'm a naive person but i would say you
know don't attribute um malice what you can
to um well the the actual quote
of stupidity but i would say um
unawareness forgiving frank you're very forgiving
um very uh yeah very people say i'm nice i think
i'm pretty nice but listen it is annoying
sometimes i mean like because it's like you
know people work hard and i understand that it's
like what are we well you know we're all trying
to do something here we all think for me it's
about the the you know it's about um a lot of
it has just has to do with the people i'm like
just talk to these these folks and they all have
their own interesting stories of how they got here
and they have good intentions so when i see like
you know certain certain sort of like
especially like mainstream tech reporters
um just like there's like a salt that underpins
a lot of them and i think it's because maybe they
covered like the crisis or they covered the tech
boom and they think well geez like what is the
to be sure what is the catch which is part of
their job so they zero in on the what's the catch
um i would i would offer advice as to my advice
to them would be that's fine like you know
laser in on on on the [__] but like there's
there's a lot of interesting um you know
stuff that's happening i mean depending
on which vertical you're coming in from
um to to report on and highlight
um but yeah to to to my favorite
my favorite thing i've been saying
recently is uh it is it is what it is
i just love it one of our editors hates it he
says every time you say it i just want like
oohs to fall down from the ceiling on
you yes you're a very passionate person
so i'm not i'm like fairly passionate but yeah i
think so yeah yes i'm just i'm just trying to uh
you know all right okay find good stories yeah
but yeah it's a no but listen i sympathize with um
it is annoying it's definitely yeah i mean
we don't need to like we don't just go over
it but you know i'd use a different word
than annoying i'd say it's more sinister
um that annoying but anyway but let's
keep going um i'm interested to know
what the differences are between working in the
traditional media versus working in crypto um
do you feel you can be more political as
an individual do you feel you have more
freedom to say certain things and what
you see some of the main differences are
well i think um
i think that like one of the main
differences is we can get really granular
on a topic i remember trying to pitch different
stories at my previous shop and it was kind of
you kind of have to fit things into um like
a more general audience make it appealing to
you know many different types of people
not just like a crypto specific audience so
that's one benefit right like you can kind of
like write about really pedantic wonky things
um and i think that's just like the dna of our
company is you know we're not trying to you know
try to get as many clicks as possible like and
that's a that's like a broader media problem
so you can kind of spend the time to do um you
know deep dives into you know what i like is
market structure um and that's because we
have a fairly you know robust business on
the research side uh similar to like um you know
maybe like a the relationship between a bloomberg
news and and bloomberg intelligence or
the actual financial services company
so that gives you a bit more bandwidth than if
you were a buzzfeed which is solely relying on
on um on clicks um and you know it's a very it's
a bad spot to be in like i don't envy having to
um you know optimize for that and we have
done like you know we're we're still in the
early innings of of trying to figure out
you know how to you know not not optimize
from not to be clickbaity but to even
think about like how can we get this in
front of as many people as possible and you
know we're it's a fairly robust business
um so i guess that that kind of is two different
things there the first is we can get really deep
we don't have to worry about like you know
we all have our own audiences within the firm
and sometimes we want to write for a really
niche audience and that's fine if only like
a couple hundred people read it because they're
going to get it through the subscription product
and if we want to do something that like
like you know that's a little more like
um you know mainstream like i
did this fun piece on why um
larry david did the ftx um super bowl
ad i talked to the director of it
and to the folks ftx and that was more like that
was like a very like almost business insidery
like article um and we can do that too so i
i guess that's the main difference is we you
kind of can really laser in on a niche audience
you can cover things that are more mainstream
um and you have the freedom to do it and you're
and we're at least here we're not really um
we're not handcuffed by the uh the
overwhelming uh power of of the click
right i understand um the reason i asked luxury
because you know you know facebook and google
completely uh with all the ad uh market share well
the reason i ask is because uh a couple of weeks
ago i thought was quite interesting you tweeted we
sacrificed the edification and development of our
youngest americans over the last few years to make
our oldest feel more safe millions of students let
me finish millions of students are chronically
absent from school such as shame what's going
on in america right now wow really i liked it
i liked it i really liked it yeah i mean like
listen i think that i think that i i don't know
what would happen i don't think i tweeted stuff
like that in previous roles i think a lot of my
colleagues at the firm probably looked at that
and thought oh geez frank you know um but
i think it's true like you talk to regular
people and they're like they want their
kids to go back to school and it's like
you know what are we what are we doing at what
what cost everything has a everything has a
cost and i think that sometimes we don't evaluate
those those costs properly but yeah i think that
certain sometimes um we have a
very open um spirit at the firm
um all different walks of life all different
stripes and colors and i we all express ourselves
um good and as long as we're respectful i mean
there are people on the team that are you know
right on the other side and um it's honestly
really unique not to not to you know be um
too chilly but i don't know if there's many
places like that where you can have people
tweet stuff like that and then tweet things
that are antithetical to it and then like
really like get to work at you know eight nine
and then just like really champion for each other
um but yeah i think you know i think like
it's it's a good thing to to you know for
for some of my colleagues to like i roll a
tweet like that and then when when they do
something similar i i roll at it as well and
then maybe we talk about it maybe we don't
get the job done and and really respect
the actual craft of what we're doing um
so here's the thing that was really spicy i think
after that one i probably you should do that more
often i like it i want to see more of that kind
of frank um it's good i think that um you see the
fact that you can get on and you know still enjoy
the work that you do together i actually think
is unique to crypto um because you ask what's
going on in america right now and i think
it's not just america it's globally it's that
people are now identifying themselves by their
political beliefs so i actually used to i'm a
journalist by trade and i used to journalists i
don't have any political beliefs at all okay sure
for sure so i have so i'm a journalist by trade
um i used to work as a journalist and um there
was this one start this one thing that happened
that i'll never forget so i'll share it with you
i was working in the newsroom on a sunday and
you know on a sunday there's only a few people
in there it's very intimate it's quite cozy um
and it's just generally not super um professional
um i was working in london um and i was based in
kensington and right around the corner from where
our news office was um in kensington the sexiest
actor lives right around the corner henry cavill
right he played superman he lives right around
the corner and so the women in the office yeah
he's great so the women in the office used to say
oh you know he lives around the corner i once
bumped into him when i was getting a coffee
um and so i was like i don't know what i said
but but i was just like oh i love henry cavill
um and one of my colleagues turned around to me
and was just like ugh i hate him and i was like
and she's a serious feminist so i said oh why
because of his comments about the metoo campaign
um and she said um yeah you know he he's horrible
he's this he's that and like this this woman went
off on me in the office um because i'm because
i because he said some comments about the me too
campaign i was like well i like him i don't really
care um and she went off on me in the office and
it was so unprofessional so inappropriate um and
it was just truly incredible it was just like a
feminist going absolutely nuts um because i
i thought henry cavill was quite hot um and
that is and that is like the epitome i think
of the workspace at the moment particularly in
journalism because you do have a lot of activists
um um masquerading as journalists um so i think
that and being able to sort of put your opinions
aside and get on and work is unique to crypto
yeah well i think you know going back to the top
of the conversation it like it's not something
that you know someone like sbf is trying
to meme into existence i do think that the
the um the makeup of the spaces is rather
wide-ranging um and i hope that you know you
know there's some elements i mean some of it is
pretty grotesque like the things that people say
i mean but this has always been the case with the
internet but but even in crypto like i you know
you know people do not hold back behind their um
anonymous avatars when when sort of engaging with
people and so it can be intimidating but at the
same time um you know i think when you actually
like get into the dms of these these folks
or you you meet them in person you can really
i think most are fairly reasonable um but at least
from my experience i mean at the block like just
very open-minded um speak your mind and and and
and without a fear of reprisal from you it is
what it is it's what it it is what it
is it is what it is um but it's it's
you know it's it's you know what happens
frank though when it is what it is
people say is what it is and then they
and then they vote with their feet
so i've left london i've left that liberal crazy
yeah of course because it is what it is i go where
it is i don't like what it was i like what it is
what do you think of florida um i love it very
much i think it's amazing um excuse me humidity
in june though have you been there oh i've
no but it's but i can feel the humidity it's it's
pretty nuts but it is what it is frankly so i'm
not surrounded by crazy bahamas bahamas is not um
humid at all okay maybe i should just move there
instead that was actually the biggest surprise
the biggest takeaway from the bahamas was that
it's it's kind of i guess like if you look
at it from like a geographical perspective
um kind of like in line with north carolina or
south carolina in the states so those are very
humid places but i guess because you have to talk
to a geologist or meteorologists i don't know who
but i assume because it's in the middle of the
ocean it's just so breezy and like insanely
pleasant good like one of the like
least humid places i've ever been to
so this episode was sponsored by the bahamas
no i'm just kidding i was just going no no um
definitely no it was really nice i will do um i
have another story i just need your take on um
i want to ask you about elon musk versus jeff
bezos um and the media's reaction to that so
elon musk wants to buy twitter and it's the end
of the world the writer is taking over not that
he's even particularly right-wing on anything
we wouldn't really know because he's not really
said his political opinions yet um but when jeff
bezos wants to buy the washington post that is a
beautiful cultural shift that is changing america
and we should all be very interested um yeah
my um uber driver um on the
way was actually south african
right um the one who dropped me off just
from the airport uh an hour and a half ago um
and he asked me about what i thought
and it's interesting i think that
he like there is this desire right like you don't
want you don't want misinformation out
there but you kind of have to you know
there's there's a balance between restricting
speech and trying to control misinformation and
it's very difficult and i spoke with this guy who
was an early advisor to facebook um a few weeks
ago right after when when the must thing came out
and i did not think that it would get this far
i was like you know it's funny internally we're
like should we prepare a story about like what
this means for crypto i was like i don't think
this is gonna happen right like this isn't gonna
actually transpire but anyway so be that as a may
i still hop down the phone with this person and
i'm trying to pull up my notes but we talked about
like this like the the difficulty around like
trying to ensure that like you have um
like a forum a place where people can like
express themselves and also like clamp down on
on you know like actual misinformation harmful
information information that can hurt people and
it's it's not easy i think that people certain
people might view like everyone's knee-jerk
everyone sees things hit the wire and they
like you know even you know with with elon
like people thought oh you know he's going to
completely open it up to the most insane strains
of society and people it's going to be like
lord of the flies and people will
be able to do whatever they want
um i think some other people look at them think
okay like you know finally there's gonna be
you know there's gonna be it's gonna
be maybe decentralized to a degree
or there's going to be you know a clamp down on
the bots and it's it's not going to necessarily be
held to the whim of the public zeitgeist or
the you know ever shifting public opinion
which is good um because you can kind of focus
on what what makes a user experience good um and
yeah i i don't know twitter has its problems
i think that it remains to be seen what
elon will do with it but i certainly don't
think that it's i mean like twitter's like
needs need some work so it's a good story that's
another it's an interesting story i think that
like the i think that the left has somehow
become a bit um like there's like almost like a
like the word censorship like it's like scary
to a degree because because there are i think
scary people who you know would like to not be
censored so right how do you how do you balance
that like from their perspective and and and
that resonates with me like i understand but um
i think like it you know just it it it it is
what it is no it's not just it is what it is
but i think we'll see we'll see what he can do i
i'm very excited about like the potential [__]
crypto elements that he could add to to the site
to the experience what kind of cryptic elements do
you think he's going to add dogecoin for tipping
yeah i think that would be pretty cool yeah i mean
that people lose their mind i mean they just
i i honestly don't like people really hate him
right like i don't understand that i think he's
like really interesting mm-hmm i think it is going
to be interesting it is going to be interesting
um i think that it's sad and bizarre and weird
that we have to put our faith in a in a
centralized individual in order to maintain
well it's like but but it doesn't work people
have tried to do these decentralized crypto social
media come back into the framework i can't see
you by the way sorry they just they just suck you
know that's the thing like that's probably early
frank we're still early yeah it's tough it's it's
it's like you know all right someone go build
it then because oh yeah trying i don't know
but i i agree i agree with with the with the
takeover i think that you know this is the best
that we have because the decentralized versions
don't work um so i'm with you on that um i think
that so far it seems that he is somebody
who is going to protect freedom of speech
um and i think to be honest like he put it
really nicely he sort of said that twitter has
become this town hall of public discussion um and
it's true it's become this global consciousness
and i think to be removed from it is um a kind of
violation um of i think it's i don't know i'd go
as far as to say it's like a violation violation
of of a right a violation of freedom of speech
um because i often say that like you can scream
from your balcony right and say i don't agree with
what the government's doing um i can scream from
my streets and the rooftops but if nobody can hear
you and if you don't have an audience then you
don't actually have freedom of speech um you need
access to people otherwise there is no freedom
of speech it's like if a tree falls in the woods
and nobody sees it did it even fool right um so
i think that i and i hope that he is going to
allow more freedom of speech um and sort of take
us down this new path where censorship is less
um or even non-existent um i don't know we'll have
to see how it goes yeah i mean there's a lot of
weird stuff on twitter so you know that there's
a hardcore porn on twitter did you know that
i've never seen it yeah hardcore porn and i
i know this because i don't actually know who
but somebody i followed must have liked something
and it came up on my page yeah it's hardcore porn
on twitter um but you're not allowed to sort
of like maybe misgender somebody by accident
um and that that basically removes you
from um the public um there's an old um
joke that ronald reagan told when he was president
i don't know what made me think of this but it's
funny so i'm gonna share with your audience and
it's an american and a russian arguing about which
one of their countries is better and the american
says i can go right into the white house i can
pound i can go right into the oval office and
pound on the president's desk and say mr president
i don't like the way you're running your country
and the russian says i can do that the american
says you can because sure i can go right into the
kremlin i can run right up to the premiere's desk
i can slam in his desk and say mr premier i don't
like the way ronald reagan's running his country
oh man i don't think you can do that wasn't
that what jan6 was all about he had a lot of
a lot of good jokes who reagan yeah he did i
liked him yeah he had he had he used to keep
him on like postcards physical postcards front to
back index cards index cards not postcards um and
just tell them that was like his thing sign
at the times yeah why are you my great aunt
um yeah but we'll see i mean like i hope that i
i hope that it's good because i think twitter is
it is like where we all are you know it's a
global consciousness it just is and if you're
cut off from it then that's a violation of
freedom of speech in my opinion yeah but
it's also a private company so it's like
you know they they can they can deem who
is within this forum and not right because
there is that they have their own freedoms
i mean i mean we have laws about like it's like
anything just like anything else yeah i mean we
have laws about like you know discrimination
laws and like equal pay laws and things like
that you know you could say it was a private
company they could decide how they want to pay
there's a fine line right like like
if i own if i run a bar like there's
a fine line like what i think of someone
being an [__] is probably different from
what maybe a different bar manager thinks
of someone being an [__] freedom of speech
yeah it's just like compelled i don't
i mean i don't know like what like
but but if it's your like house or
bar or whatever company you know you
you can kind of set the parameters
around i'm playing devil's advocate
no i agree with you though what what is what what
is allowed in this forum or within this place
which is why you know we know that freedom
of speech is better and so i hope that
you know elon musk up holds it and um i'm still
i'm just fascinated about the way the media has
covered it um and i'm interested to watch how the
media continues to change and shift and present
things in different ways um whatever you should
get you should get them on the show you know
me oh thank you yeah yeah you included it was
great chatting to you frank any time listen long
time listener first time caller i love it that's
great um would you have any final thoughts where
can people start following you how can people keep
up with your work and what's going on at the block
yeah i mean i have it i have a show as well um
probably not as well listened to as um as yours
but it's the scoop podcast and i am at the twitter
for now who knows i could get blocked by elon
let's see who knows what he's going to do you'll
be to think at fintech frank that i loved all the
tweets about like people going back and saying i
got to delete all my auntie elon tweets but that's
it goes back to your point at the end of
the day and this would be my closing thought
yeah no matter where you sit when you
are entrusting any company or or person
or centralized entity whether you're on
the right side of it or the left side of it
you're at the whim of the discretion of
that person and so who knows who could
have came in and bought twitter could have
been any sort of you know well really hard
to construct a deal like that but could have
been someone who maybe didn't agree with you
and you'd be cast out or someone who does and then
they cast out the other side you know you really
that's what that's what you're you know that's
the sort of social contract that exists there um
but we yeah we shall see it is what it is
and when you say is what it is that leads to
serious consequences people will start voting with
their feet um and um you know they'll always be
reactions to every every action has a consequence
um and i think we're at a pivotal moment in time
so i'm excited to see how it all goes um frank it
was so great having you on the show today thank
you so much for coming on thank you thank
you yeah absolute pleasure and guys thank
you so much for watching don't forget to follow
frank and if you are watching on youtube please
hit the subscribe button and the like button so
you never miss a video we'll see you next week